bonjour et bienvenue au club de
l'économie alors jean marc jancovici
bonjour dans le contexte actuel de
croissance faible de contraintes
environnementales de plus en plus forte
comment voyez vous l'avenir de la
consommation énergétique dans le monde
ce qu'on est en train de constater
aujourd'hui au plan mondial c'est qu'on
commence à voir apparaître une double
facture celle des ressources non
renouvelables dans lequel on a tapé pour
l'essor industriel dont certaines
commencent à souffrir est par ailleurs
celle de l'exutoire c'est-à-dire tout ce
qu'on déverse dans l'environnement et
commence à y avoir un peu trop et donc
qu'il s'agisse des conditions de vie des
poissons dans la mer ou de la quantité
de co2 dans l'atmosphère il ya un
certain nombre d'endroits où les
poubelles commençaient à déborder
on va dire alors sur le plan économique
il ya d'énergie plus on transforme et
plus on veut transformer plus il faut
d'énergie
donc plus on veut de pib plus il faut
d'énergie puisque le pib mesure avec des
euros cette fois ci la transformation
aujourd'hui on rentre dans un cadre
contraint sur le pétrole à l'échelle
mondiale
en fait on dire on y rentre il ya dix
ans à peu près en 2005 2006 la
production mondiale de pétrole brut
donc pas de liquide globalement mais de
pétrole brut s'est arrêtée de croître
il s'en est ensuivi des troubles
économiques aux etats-unis retournement
des prix de l'immobilier ralentissement
de la croissance etc qui a débouché sur
une crise financière et on connaît la
suite l'économie qui s'est mise à
tourner au ralenti en fait l'économie ne
s'est pas redressée derrière parce que
le pétrole ne s'est pas redressée et on
rentre aujourd'hui dans un contexte dans
lequel comme le pétrole va plafonner
pendant encore quelques années avant de
commencer à décroître
on va avoir une économie qui sera de
plus en plus contraintes dire qu'on est
contraint ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
choisir
et comme on a par ailleurs les problèmes
environnementaux qui croissent et qui
continue à croître pour traiter ces
problèmes environnementaux il va falloir
faire d'abord ce qui permet de se
débarrasser de la plus grande partie du
problème
en dépensant le moins d'argent possible
donc on va devoir suivre une règle si on
veut préserver la paix parce que c'est
bien ça le sujet préserver les problèmes
environnementaux
c'est préserver la paix on a besoin de
la planète pour vivre
eh bien on va devoir commencer par
s'attaquer au problème en dépensant le
moins d'argent possible pour régler
quelque chose et par exemple dans le
cadre du climat ça veut dire qu'il faut
commencer à s'attaquer au problème en
dépensant le moins d'euros possible pour
éviter une tonne de co2 c'est ça qui
doit être la grande règle qui doit nous
inspirer à partir de maintenant parce
que dans un monde sans croissance
on n'a plus le temps de faire et ses
erreurs ce qui caractérise les sociétés
en croissance vous faites un truc ça
marche pas bien oui c'est pas grave j'ai
le temps devant moi pour corriger les
bêtises parce qu'effectivement une
société en croissance de plus en plus de
moyens
donc si vous n'avez pas bien fait du
premier coup vous corriger après société
sans croissance est une société où si
vous dépensez votre argent sur un truc
qui sert à rien par construction vous
l'avez plus pour le dépenser sur quelque
chose qui sert de manière effective et
dans ce contexte donc vous vous dites
la solution ce ne sont pas les énergies
renouvelables mais c'est le nucléaire
alors pourquoi si je suis un peu plus
précis quand on est dans un pays des
moyennes latitudes
donc l'europe qu'on a le soleil qu'on a
au moyen de l'attitude je rappelle que
ce qui caractérise la latitude c'est
l'insolation c'est l'angle par rapport
au soleil et que par ailleurs on a du
vent sur les côtes mais beaucoup moins
une fois qu'on rentre dans l'intérieur
des terres
penser qu'on va substituer un mode qui
est pilotable comme le nucléaire et qui
dans des conditions économiques que je
pourrai qualifiée de normale n'est pas
si cher que ça par quelque chose qui
dépend du soleil pas très abondants aux
moyennes latitudes et du vent et
derrière lequel il faut rajouter une
couche pour rendre le système pilotable
parce que on ne va pas se faire si on
veut vivre demain matin dans une société
où les trains n'avance que quand il ya
du vent ou que quand il ya du soleil ça
va poser quelques petits problèmes
d'organisation qu'on ne sait pas gérer
aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui on est dans un monde
dans lequel il faut qu'on rendre
l'électricité disponible quand l' usage
en face est vraiment
là et à ce moment ça veut dire que les
modes non pilotable on doit les
compléter de quelque chose qui permet de
les rendre à nouveau pilotable et le
coup système de cet ensemble très faible
quand on a quelques pourcents
d'électricité non pilotable devient
dominant quand on se met à avoir
essentiellement ça les villes aux tables
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas le
stocker en quelle ça veut dire qu'on ne
peut pas décider quand la production
arrive voilà c'est pas vous qui décidez
quand il ya du vent ou du soleil corps
alors qu'avec une centrale à charbon et
à gaz hydraulique de l'arrière et on la
reprend vous décidez quand l'électricité
arrive vous tourner le bouton et vous en
avez plus ou moins donc dans un dans un
monde où vous auriez essentiellement de
l'électricité non pilotable tout le
système qu'il faut mettre autour pour
qu'on continue à avoir à l'aval des
choses qui fonctionnent à peu près et
que vous fassiez pas non plus votre
lessive avec une machine à laver juste
quand il ya du vent ou du soleil et bien
le coup système de cette affaire il est
10 à 40 fois plus élevé qu'avec du
nucléaire dit autrement si vous regardez
les investissements qui sont nécessaires
pour avoir la même quantité
d'électricité sur l'année
quand vous avez vraiment envie de
consommer de l'électricité même si on
peut décaler quelques petits trucs
eh bien il faut mettre 10 à 40 fois plus
d'argent sur la table
si vous avez éoliens ou solaires plus
les moyens de compenser l'intermittence
que si vous avez du nucléaire et je
pense que dans la société en
décroissance dont je viens de parler
juste avant nous n'aurons pas cet argent
et donc si on se dit je veux éviter du
charbon et du gaz dans la production
électrique juste avec des éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires et les moyens de
stocker derrière on n'y arrivera pas
donc il faut prendre le risque du
nucléaire donc il faut prendre le risque
du nucléaire absolument parce que ce
risque est somme toute beaucoup moins
important que le risque de pas de
nucléaire qui est le risque d'un
changement climatique et d'un
approvisionnement économique
déclinant rapidement avec derrière les
troubles économiques donc sociaux et
politiques qu'on va avoir et un jour
comme l'a très bien décrit marcel
boiteux il ya dix ans si on a une décrue
énergétique subi qui va trop vite on se
retrouvera en dictature indépendamment
de tout problème de changement
climatique je n'ai pas très envie de ça
alors nous sommes à quelques mois enfin
la cap 21 a fermé ses portes il y a
quelques mois
des grands des engagements ont été pris
notamment en termes de réduction des
hausses de température alors quel est
selon vous quelles sont selon vous les
mesures à prendre d'urgence pour essayer
de respecter ses engagements
l'engagement qui a été pris à paris
c'est à dire les fameux 2 degrés de
hausse de température ou une traduction
physique tu majeur qui est que les
émissions planétaires doivent être
divisées par trois d'ici à 2050 donc je
prends les émissions actuelles et jeudis
en 2050 je n'aimais plus que le tiers de
sa à ce moment ça donne c'est comme au
patinage artistique quelques figures
imposées c'est à dire il ya des choses
auxquelles on n'échappera pas si on veut
respecter cet objectif
une des choses auxquelles on échappera
pas c'est de supprimer le charbon dans
la production électrique
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui il y à
1800 gigawatts de centrales à charbon
dans le monde
c'est à dire 30 fois plus que les
centrales nucléaires françaises
et c'est sans hills en ouvre tous les
jours et j'en ouvre tous les jours
jusqu'à une période récente c'est moins
vrai maintenant mais la chine mettait en
service toutes les semaines l'équivalent
d'une centrale nucléaire mais au charbon
donc en une année il avait installé la
capacité française nucléaire à peu de
choses près mais au charbon le charbon a
augmenté sur les 15 dernières années 35
fois plus que le solaire serre si je
prends ce qu'on a fait en plus sur le
solaire sur les 15 dernières années
je multiplie par 35 et ça me donne ce
que j'ai fait en plus sur le charbon
absolument monstrueux et bien ses
centrales à charbon il faut tout s'en
débarrasser d'ici à 2030 à 2,6 à 2050 si
on veut être sérieux parce que le
charbon c'est 20% des centrales à
charbon c'est 20% des émissions
mondiales donc on décrète tout de suite
l'arrêt des centrales à charbon donc ça
sauf que on s'est pas dans les mains de
l'onu
donc en fait quand à paris on dit il
faut 2 degrés seulement d'ici à 2100 ça
veut dire qu'on s'est donné un résultat
mais ce n'est pas l'onu qui a la main
sur les leviers de l'action parce que
c'est pas les nations unies qui décide
ou pas si on construit des centrales à
charbon dans un pays où si on les arrête
donc ce qui s'est décidé à paris ça doit
être transposée derrière dans des
politiques qui sont nationales il ya un
peu moins de 200 pays dans le monde où
supranationale et coordonnée par des
entités qui en
mandat comme par exemple l'union
européenne mais pas que cet essentiel de
garder en tête que de diviser par trois
les émissions mondiales c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne sait pas faire
si on ne supprime pas toutes les
centrales à charbon il ya plein d'autres
choses qu'on ne sait pas faire
enfin pendant qu'on doit faire si on
veut diviser par trois les émissions on
va avoir beaucoup de mal à garder la
production actuelle de ciment et d'acier
qui à elles deux fonds 10 % des
émissions mondiales
on va avoir beaucoup de mal à continuer
à manger autant de boeuf sachant que
l'alimentation c'est pas loin de 30 %
des émissions mondiales
on va avoir du mal à conserver autant
d'objets qui circulent sur terre parce
que les transports ces 15% des émissions
mondiales
donc on va avoir beaucoup de choses à
faire en même temps et c'est la raison
qui nous renvoie au début de cet échange
qui fait que quand on a beaucoup de
choses à faire en même temps on peut pas
dilapider des milliards juste sur un
caprice parce que du coup on n'est plus
capable de faire toutes ces choses en
même temps très bien et bien jean marc
jancovici merci et rendez vous donc au
prochain club de l'économie